c'est l'idée de la
bardane on a eu quand un résident
permanent n'a pas droit de voter
ne s'intéressent pas parce que il n'a
pas son mot à dire
les élections se suivent trop proche
donc oui d'un terrible
et si tu rends hommage un clash at
on essayé de ne pas penser à son camp ça
nous affecte grandement mais quand on
massacre elle veut puis lé travail parce
qu'elles se sentent un peu inconfortable
pour l'heure guère différemment de
celle là elle vient du maroc maxi à la
menthe fraîche on met avec le thé donc
il ya parfois la nostalgie je pense que
même si on a une mort d'ici mais on
préfère la vérité
est ce que c'est a priori musulmans dont
la conjoncture actuelle ce n'est pas de
moi c'est une phase une priorité les
premiers c'est plus sécuritaire
nous sommes dans un pays démocratique
et donc tout le monde a le droit de
mettre des signes religieux ou
s'habiller comme il veut mais simplement
qu'il faut mettre des balises
allez y
si vous retournez les sahraouis
pensée du projet de charte des valeurs
je suis
pour ça toutefois il faut quand même
respecter l'autre comme moi je respecte
le québécois les clés mais quoi j'ai
droit de respect de la part du québec
robert c'est ce qui fait la richesse du
tfc multiethnique
c'est vraiment cosmopolite c'est ce sens
la richesse du québec il a un départ
lancé le projet souverainiste ici ça me
dérange pas tant d'avoir un passeport
québécois ou canadiens qu'à peu près la
même chose c'est du pareil au même
et guarana ça c'est très connu c'est les
liqueurs nationale du brésil
un québec souverain ça pourrait être
quelque chose d'intéressant si pensez
vous que sa production moins d'un mois
je pense je pense c'est je pense qu un
pays indépendant iranien appelle